it's like when you have kids is it about
your happiness or is it about the kids
happiness
i think it kind of can play a role as
water because if
you stay together you could actually be
bringing like more of a toxic
environment so if you stay together with
like pure arguments right our life
it could end up just getting like and i
guess if it is
toxic like that naturally it can get
like i guess like a bit manipulative
it's just like power
maybe if you break up it might be a
better relationship actually might be
better for the kids if you actually
separate because you can then
live a better life as a as a
can i follow up on that i agree with
what he said because i feel like also
like even when you bring up your kids in
that environment you're kind of showing
your kids what they're going to want to
accept in the future like personally me
like i want to show my kids like a way
of living and i feel like
if i'm showing them that yeah i'm
staying in like an unhappy relationship
because they're going to sense it we all
live in the same house like how are you
not like my kids aren't going to be
stupid
like so for me it's like i'm showing
them oh it's okay to stay in an unhappy
marriage but i don't want my kids to
feel like just because you're obliged to
your kids like because you could really
teach their moles like just because
we're co-parenting and we're separated
or divorced etcetera doesn't mean but
you really statistically like how much
of a disadvantage you are if you don't
have both parents in the house
even if you are dividing that really
good yeah like you're still at a
disadvantage because it's not the same
no it's like but i'm gonna be honest i
don't i don't i don't i don't know them
like these stats off the top of my head
but like you're much more likely to
commit a crime if you're not raised with
both parents in the house you're much
more likely to drop out of school like
every stat that possible like i promise
if you spend five minutes researching
this like
is
it says it's better to have both parents
in the house
so entry
you're
u.s but i would be shocked if it's
different here i would be shocked but
then statistically more people get
divorced in the u.s than the uk in
general like is that true for sure
do you think it's because less people
get married here
do you think because because um the
average age of first marriage in the uk
is 31 where it's 27 in the us for women
anyway
i just
30 31
in the uk for average age of first
marriage well i i know obviously i'm not
statistic i don't know if it's like
taken into account because obviously
like if it is a broken home it could be
possible like
one of the parents might be just gone
saying so like
all the people that may be like
are living like the single pair of life
obviously maybe that is a disadvantage
but
the if the both parents were there
contributing like i'm being i guess
being role models in that way
i feel like
maybe this is six one reflect that as
such
um i mean it probably i'm sure it's
better like
if the dad or the mom like whatever one
is out of the house like is in their
life
but i just can't imagine a world where
like it's better to have
them in separate houses than into one
you see it though when you go around
families christmas is better
boy
one picture
like it doesn't mean the child is like
doomed it can't do anything it's just
like if you leave you're putting your
kids at every statistical disadvantage
possible and it's for what you for your
happiness but you're supposed to love
your kids more than you like if we're in
a relationship and we're not happy i
feel like the thing that we could agree
on is our children's happiness and we're
going to try to figure out stuff for our
children's happiness yeah yeah that's
what that's the relationship but then
also it's like you have to at what point
you consider your own happiness you have
your own one life like honestly huh of
course you have your kids no listen but
it's not that they're gonna be
like it's not like the world is at end
like they can't move on you have your
mom you have your dad they're not
together but like but like which is a
lot more if you're staying together and
you're unhappy on a daily basis with
someone that is obviously the reason
you're unhappy with them they've ever
hurted you or like hurt you you know huh
[Music]
man i ever heard you're like something's
happened to cause like this rift in
like seriousness but do you think that
possibly like it's something that you
yourself have to work on because it
takes two in a relationship
so if you're arguing all the time like
it takes someone to argue with of course
but you'd be unhappy in something in a
situation not about yourself you'd be
like because that's something you would
address with your partner like oh i
don't like this about myself or i don't
think like they would argue about yo
you're not doing this or
i could get to them
you'll get like we'll get mad pet people
like when you don't like something about
someone else if you really care about
someone you're like i have like you
don't want to see them angry at you you
put your own feelings aside at the start
yeah but obviously like if we're talking
about what happened with something about
doing this for 18 years above being
unhappy for 18 years that's the 10 year
10-year hits from like it's my bro like
man's arguing about the craziest things
that's uh
craziest things like things are so
irrelevant 10 years in your life like
i just don't think things are forever
like i think it shouldn't be like
yeah marriage for well seriously i think
like at five
i think no no no i mean more in the fact
of like every five years like kind of
sit down kids are involved or not just
like are you happy can i do anything
more what is what's good in our
relationship what's bad in our
relationship this whole
happy forever is just a perfect thing
it's a fairy tale i've been married i've
been married
i believe in it yeah and i tried to stay
in my marriage so and would i get
married again absolutely so i'm saying
would you think like you just said like
as in like you wouldn't stay with that
person like you made it sound like you'd
rethink like no i just think no i'm
saying i'm saying conversations yeah i'm
saying in a marriage and any even in a
relationship doesn't even have to get to
a marriage point even with your
girlfriend you're free four or five
years in and you're like
you know and i think this is a nice way
for men to come to the table like
actually you're not doing this how you
used to or and this is the comfortable
bit or i would like you to do this or i
really enjoy this we need to go on dates
more we need to go out like i think
that's where the comfortable bit comes
in of the years you start to lose
yourself you gain a hundred pounds
you're never going to happen i feel like
that comes in just like no relationships
in general more so but she's like
progressing into that marriage yeah
still continue that yeah because when
you're married for 10 years like you're
not saying like you're questioning like
that but when you're married for 10
years that you this is a part of your
routine like it's a part you wouldn't
get that unhappy before you i think
that's why she's like emphasizing on
that comfortability so she's saying like
going into that like in the process of
going into marriage and even after
marriage like 10 years in like continue
having those conversations because it's
good to be updated
how your husband or wife feels um like
what they think and what their where
their thoughts are because you know as
people but actually we evolve each day
we evolve like ev all the time so maybe
my likes have changed maybe my dislikes
have changed so i think it's good to
like have those open conversations i
have that open line of communication
that's why the real question is are like
humans like should they be with like one
person oh yeah like yeah you know back
in the day that's not that's how life
was
no that's not how life was that's how
humans
well you know it used to be like
polygamy used to be the norm where it
would be like a very small percentage of
men would have multiple wives
and multiple likes
it switched to monogamy but that was
that was later but now we're starting to
see the trend go back where it's like a
smaller percentage of men with multiple
girls or women
what
why does it have to be men well because
because women are more selective than
men
they can still have multiple partners
well they can but um
but i'm just saying the name put on it
like you said that's a hoe that's that's
the label you're choosing to
and men men biologically had to ensure
paternity so there's a reason they're
disgusted by multiple partners with a
woman because historically if there was
a girl that was sleeping around he could
not ensure paternity and you can't make
that even though it's not even though
it's not like
even though even though even though it's
not it's not like we don't like it and
it might it's probably not convenient
today because most of the girls you like
are probably attractive and they
probably have had multiple partners but
like
but but what i'm saying is like even
though it's not like yeah fun they can't
they can't and women
yeah they can't get rid of their biology
where women we what we're attracted to
is like status you know height success
money
reliability
but statistically
that was she he ate
on my show
he might be he's gonna say because i
always talk about
it's a stereotype but if we lived in a
life where everything's just a
stereotype it's like what's the point
because there's an exception there's an
exception to every rule but even you
like you realize like 95 of couples the
woman is shorter than the man like
that's that's very much an exception i'm
like
off the scale from the right six foot
four i'm not what are they called
no
well